Jhal
A My Name is Tejas Chopra I Am Senior
Software Engineer Edison Should Be Talking About
Carbon Footprint All Over Software
Development I Hope You All Hard Good Line
Channel Try My Best Hot Photo After Sleep
With Light Off
108 Interested In This Topic Beginners In
The recent floods of talk about bitcoin
box in the impact on environment and
development of reflection
directly
subscribe to understand things from
subscribe
to what carbon footprints of things but lord
of greenhouse gas emissions
doba products process people
organization and different types of
greenhouse gas acid butter oil  Measured in
terms of the equivalent warming potential
of carbon dioxide just one
number 222
so its president information is for this particular
planet its poise capital
carbon dioxide emissions and different nations
and
avoid the United States
effigy of carbon dioxide agree with us
note talk about carbon  Dioxide in
General You May Think The Biggest Contributors
Bring Back Virat Carbon Dioxide A Aaj
Bhi Ringtone Tributes To Parts Of
Carbon Dioxide Birthday Per Person However The
Total Use Interesting Country Five Elements
Account Print And Carbon Dioxide And
Vid U
Ka Pyaar Laptop Ahmed Around Point 850
Comment Website Day The Modem Is 1.4 Day Day
A Little Activity Account 14% Top 10
Haunted Pass Birthday Status For 5th Day On
Person
's Size Trip MH 500 Carbon Dioxide
A Vent For Traffic Smiles
That China Sample Village Of Rohtak Respect Is
Point 8.1  Dioxide Tattoo Agro Agencies
In Festive Season And Export
8500 Ka Website Is Just Read And The
Match Se Side Se
500 Banana
Subscribe
Banana To 1000 V The Coming Back To The Topic Of Digital
Activity
That Anime Is Simple Text Email MS
Around For Ounces Of Carbon  Dioxide
in the damaged houses of carbon
dioxide it is not just user or the
client-side directly into death sexual
infrastructure developed data center
networking years everything oo
that boat animal content data data gas
replicated and stored in worldly
pleasurable and detergent printable female
content attachments video  And audio
files is up to like a Times of India
website
that at percent of the transfer of data that
region of world today is video streaming
and from 108 to that is wealth and mid
subscribe to
or artificial intelligence and per companies
Lord of actually boasted of  Artificial
Intelligence Really Help in the World and Its Tak Is Tarf But I Must Also Be
Mindful of Singh Dimpa Artificial
Intelligence on Environment and Water Tank
205 To Write Grammar in a Sentence
Meanwhile in Delhi Has to the Blind Side of
the Dark Side of  Klans Device Use
Everyday However Only Thirty Five Percent of Admissions
is Peer Website at 65 Cents From the First
President of the Data Centers Networking
This Networking Infrastructure Data to You Is
This Is a Chart of iPhone 12th and Its
Website
Developed Mentions The Missions Fast 70
Pass  AB
1283 Sent During
Transportation and
Uses video.com
A Defense Against Written By Inviting a Very Good
Perspective About Different
Carbon Footprint Benchmarks and Right
Flight Bin Yagya Not Only This Account
Website Human Life Is 1100 500 American
Life Located 108
Km A US Card Including  Fuel Is
Zinc War Manufacturing Not
Interesting Transformer Which Are Not
Being With Parameters And Moral Conduct
Research Well Take
0.5
Off
This Is Better Thing And Interesting And
Mean When Is The Impact Of Technology Is
That Aviv
University Worked And There Impact On
Environment
That Tamil Videos In The Course Of Black
Lips On Main
Aa Badri Direct Vijay Depending On
Ande Calculated The Amount Of Carbon
Dioxide Emitted By One Hour Of
Streaming Videos In Europe And
Networks Around 5 Grams Subscribe Button On Side
That And Service Network Transmission Home Right
End  Consumes back office patient data
centers in the network problem and consuming some
of the blind side
footprints on
how to put things into a specific mission
buried power of video is rifle
event
microwaving three and half cups and around
2.5 times of India introduction missions youth  Two
meters
that another way to come back as a browser and you have
one Lord of the Rings width I have taken
are electric kettle to minute boy 2019
minutes streaming video on Netflix
and LED lamp for what is equal to
three minutes microwave to
zinc  Treatment Simple
subscribe The
Video then
subscribe to
be lit Green House Gas Company to and
subscribe our
back door 2012 hai
tu bhai tu yahan par ko ke andar par
cent of little activity hoon main aashiq
ke andar itne saare it's growing every year
special 228 par  Saints in the Universe and
14% Today the World is the Language 345 Se
Types of Data in the Types of Bayan
Petites and Now Alien 1500 Use This Number Away This
Only Expansion in Growing
a Letter at This Point Saints Are Almost Completely Under the
Control of Developers
One day or the other, there is a sea of ​​software
techniques that come favorite about these different
research articles which can help today this is
my nominative list is habituated to initiate everyone's mind as to the
everyday you can
get benefit environment
that I have come to Polytechnic Bihar CPU and
round in  Terms of Devotion Carbon
footprint for CPU is to get into all
lower power states as soon as possible so all the co
decreases right left can bring higher
power states as it is at this point the cent
growth was in
that choosing a patient mathematical operations for
example IF  You Multiply
GiveInstitute Summation All The Best
Compilers World Most Welcome First
Student Birthday Se Just To See Developers Can Do
Adherent Hai
Refueling Computers Hai
Angrezon Singh Conditioner Branch
Exams To The Tune Of Prevention What Is
My Using Local Barriers And Global
Variables Values ​​Were Vested
Interests
That Radio Singh's Code Size Eliminating
Date Code Will Also Have Been Impossible Account
Print The
Increasing Special Temperature Low
Quality Friends So That Lord Weight's
Thrown Away On I One Interesting Point Table Looking
Nice Lips
A Controlling Open Loop Sudeshwar
Interesting Apparently You Dare This Work  Done
in every situation will look into a more work
on tradition and reduce the amount of
creation date will be better for environment
in these alarms opportunity to paralyze
five withdrawals yield wealth the
morning multiple elections 2014
a moving unlock code outside a look that
and against killing  Look So That You Have
Left Conditional Branches and So You Remove the
Last Impression
Time's
Review Locator Subscribers Channel Its
Order of Boys
Are the Length of Spring Water Boiled Mode of
the Place Order and Listen to
Exploring Alarm Set Up March Past Will
Get You to Perform Your Trusted and
Bring You Back Key Test
Yo Yo Dharai Data Structures  List Comment
Data Success At Least Vinod Dasha
Located In Different Parts Of Memory From
Zoom Zoom Different Parts Of Media And
Result What Is The Message To You 600 Tours And
Travels Just Update That
Withdrawal's Textures And Generally Better Than
Polling Best Architectures Show In Polling
Institute  Actually Have And Lips Pink
Lips And After Waiting For Instructions To
Receive New Updates Reviews Architecture
0.2 Sadhe Vent To Cause Cancer
Cells Inside Back End Different Workers And
Different Consumer Durable Consumer And
Operate On The Element Servants
A Multi Setting Show A Code Is Multithreaded
Will Allah  Organized you course to be pushed to the
limits and details in fact better
for the environment Dancing Acid Code
simply requested the toss and faster and bring the versus
power state soon
a little love poster competition with user per
like share and channel lotus seated upon the
government  And After
Properly Britain Multifaceted Code Will
Give Me Only Performance Boss Was Having
Almost No Adverse Impact
That Bigg Boss Study Done For Compilers By
And Research Paper And Water Used Tubelight
Database Lights Comment Best Is Used Oil
This Android iOS Applications And Its
Compiled By Default Using  Visual C
Plus Plus Subah Just From Made Them To Change It's An
Order To Come Forward And C Plus Plus
And
Experiment With Rope Table Command2 Command1
To Hundred Times And The Amount Of Data
In Table Was Not Forget To Like This
Status Of God Very Interesting Friends  If
required time table using different less
than and its akshaya lipti science aur 50%
maazu a patient
a rule of mas is application use landing its better
for the government to be running
you win gold plus debit use not less 115
juice compact 230 seven  Bar Default Visual
C Plus Plus Compiler And Power Consumption
Slows Down
A Specific Rate Compiled Optimization
Of Wealth Namely Person Medicine Plant
Arjun Sr Juice Moving From 0 To One Or Two
Of Great Benefit In Terms Of
Energy Efficiency And All The
Best Like
Subscribe And
Key  In programming language
I am generally a software engineer also use right
tool for a job and enough you can write back
side and see what did you still want it
so hard fuk pick just programming
language as mode of art and science paper
comparison between different programming
languages ​​and amount  If energy is
energy efficient then now you can
imagine the closer view of the matter. For more energy efficient things go to get a
that you Anshu Computer Imperative Object
Oriented Function Scripting Languages
for Easy Application Study Ajit Anjum If power increases
then benefits to taste for  Energy
Efficiency Do Very Good But Doing Great As Your
Profile System Power Steering
Application One Time Understand the Impact
of Different States of Programs True
Depending Set and Examine This Can Find Success If You Just
for Fun and Craft Duet
Available Only on Sharing and
Subscribe Subscribe About
Power Power Of
Love You To See The Power Of The Question A Running
Machine The Video Then
Loot Developed By Branding Crack Which Is A
Aspect Some And Has Been Very Useful Tool For
Me To See The Hot Bath And Were Not
Present For Power And Efficiency
This Morning Daily Words
So Come Amazon World Where Today BCD
Pipelines The Taste for Preparation of
Intense
Pain in the Abdomen Changes Department
Pickup the
Future with Energy Efficiency of
Architecture for Your
Request Computer
Users Browser
subscribe and
subscribe the Channel
Ko subscribe
to
subscribe our
Some Views  Not in Points in
Architecture Share Date Video not here
Procreate Umesh Bharti Impact of Energy
and Carbon Dioxide Footprint Saw in the Future
of Belief that Will Have to Front Front
Subscribe to That
in Fact All You Something Account Online It Hath
Something in  Place where do you have
any application let's you browse for
internet and the back end drop
you can compute the subscribe The
footprint in terms of
water will
change its
network
subscribe
I am thankful and implemented in this Hai
Azhar Smart Control Do Do
's Use Energy Efficient  Appliances
and Suna Gaon Device Overnight at the
report which instituted of buying to
reduce and device footprint and
finally fixing don't like and one
more plant turn off the
missions
plant can reduce the
Executive Vice Chancellor
please subscribe that
and finally practical a that
you too Prabhu  Set up side that they always
see the actions and this comment free mode of unity entertain the world is gold
people like you to your fit and reduce and
carbon footprint 10
that Lakshman time thank you so much
primary contact information
one question is that  Same thing printer
cpu usage and network usage especially when things are
not in your control like lord
in this how do you make one mostly rule
of thumb dr
subscribe
mode on yes yes yes yes
good cyber war question aa zara something
3021 particular language and compare to  The
languages ​​and you know other is
the rockstar dj hard competition user
languages ​​in fact all the languages
coffee environment 100 5352 research about this
now i specific research points
subscribe collection comparing to belong to
connect with the best collection of languages
and not a recent survey research
Labs co
subscribe
language and a brothers people of mode velvet
use budding polyglot and several languages
using
fluid in
this yes yes good question from the president of what is
the rate of behind the plaques between
running all small number of citizens at very
hot verses  Number Officer Not
Withdraw Comparison Between Two The Experiment Which Was
Not A Good Idea To Be Amazed And
Subscribe Environment Se To The International
Ingested Asli
Subscribe
The Question On The
Pure Question Is That Is Till Carbon
Footprint Just From Fossil Fuels And
Digit Also Accounting For  Renewable
Energy Research Resurrect You OK Sorry for the
Number Subscribe Now to Receive for All and
for an Incident Transportation in Food
Production Has
Not Been Seen That You Will Be Available at
Times Now
You Can See
Hidden
and Probably
Subscribe Button Subscribe
Yes There
are Photos  Yes Adha Akshar Great Thought As Well As This
Battle On This Technique Jani Discuss Today All Sort Of Thing That At Least
Developed This
App Will Contest For Developers Private
Schools And Highlighting Damn Good Player
Losing It's An Understanding The
Thing This Vicious Developers Have Not Right  To
Build
A Better User Experience
Subscribe
Person Thing In Terms Of Productivity
Of B Id M Id
Subscribe And
Subscribe Of And UT Road Resident
Infrastructure And DAV School
Begusarai Udas Martin And Control System
Degree What Is Not Control To Reduce
Footprint
Subscribe To Dot Vice
President
Subscribe to the
Indian
Good Good Good Very Good Question Aa The
question is that is there any situation where you can
reduce
that I don't thing and cockroach situations but
ayush se the
sun tan giving sufficient algorithms is
better not in terms of unwanted terms of
Energy efficiency can fight in terms of
the coding if you really want
you can
reduce the
lines of the world to reduce the amount
of
dividend
for you
instead of response is no question of
repeated is this
application will be more and easier for
energy efficient than having  To Date and
Secondary Sources of Painful and Twitter
Application Sudhir and Because Someone and Using Mary It's
Available Free of Cost To
Data Subscribe to Bigg Boss Like
and
Subscribe
No If
in Terms of Us
To Gender Doodh Questions of Elected
President of
I 10  Watch Live Session and Hai Villiers of
Attraction and Impact on Energy Efficiency
Now Jain Take Yes More of You in
Terms of the Code of
Subscribe
to The Amazing
President of Development
subscribe
Video Like It Will Take
to
Subscribe and Subscribe
Definitely the
Effects in the Comment Section  Of the question is that now this
year doing something don't message for having same
back and give what lies
now just to provide a system where
and when he gets Bihar
subscribe and subscribe
the Shri gets into water
subscribe
this Video
And
subscribe The
Amazing
and  Field Research
And Others Like This Install Se That Vacancy
Here Opportunities To Research About This Thank You Can
All Discussions And Definition
Are Yes Either You A This Question Is That Of
Lemon Grass Hour Name Instruction Of And The
Thing Bluetooth Of But Can Get More Insights
into energy efficiency
and dedicated freight link for detail view
different
different different from what
is the number of the great
start to do subscribe my channel
click on subscribe button
yes to world class the question is the same
decorate pomegranate and video streaming with
amount of website  Increase Environment
Grabbing Interest The International Organization
Details Are Performed Evil Acts And Her
Lord Of Internal To The Place Where The
Match Award Impact Of Data Center
Subscribe The
Tarzan
The Operating System And
Subscribe Not The President Of The Number
9483 By
Subscribe
What
Yes-yes etc question is that is the rate of
thanks in me and optimizing sardar
level and no but when you get to the great
impact of channels and print this diet
change and you do do do do do do
is lake eyre of lord of time  Trying To Learn More
About This Channel Subscribe Now To
Write A Very
Little
Understanding Subscribe
I Will Not Exist At Higher Levels And All
Things Down Automatically Badshah Languages
And Am Not Always Been The Most Efficient
Way To In Terms Of Energy Half Hour
Terms Of Time  But not in terms of
animals in so doing something
subscription on this
is a question is the salary of the thing about
for 2nd division at comes to interfere
providers and changing and comparing
different types of infrastructure
projects like share and then gently into
complaints
of
internal storage  And
Amazon
Documentation
Subscribe
Subscribe To
Hai So Luck Badle Notification Of You Know The Comparison Between Different
Types Of
Carbon Footprints Mudda Problems
Related To
Ye Sab Om
Namo Questions On Ki
Kuchh Thank You So Much U [
Music]
Aur Sunao Sab Khairiyat Hai
[Music]  it's a
mess